Luke here the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel today we're here in Lake Louise
Alaska and we're ice vision
[Music]
[Applause]
hey we're not quick but we're here
I just realized something we don't have
your snow suit
oh my gosh
uh give daddy a moment to think about
this hold on man we got a little problem
here what I forgot Tommy's snowsuit it's
heated at the ice shack right right yes
I I brought an extra code I think I
might be able to pull that off okay so
we put them in the code I'll cover them
in hand warmers with shove them in the
sleeping bag and we can get them
transported to the ice jacket does that
seem reasonable that seems reasonable
I'm not a bad parent fish if I do that
okay
not that's really not good that is
correct Ransom it is really not good
well I got your
s there's no super
you want goggles well guys we're here at
the point Lodge in Lake Louise and I'm
here with Patrick with Chase and Tails
Guide Service here and uh we're excited
to go catch some big fish we were here
about what is it about a year ago yeah
almost a year ago yeah yeah had a great
time there are some monster lake trout
in here and burbit and other things and
uh we're gonna be spending two nights
three days here on the lake it's gonna
be pretty awesome yeah looking forward
to it
foreign
are you okay
I can't feel my legs but I'm okay
here we are
middle Lake Louise it is a balmy warm 12
degrees outside so it's almost 50
degrees warmer than the last time we
were here all right guys check it out
we've got some ice shacks here
got a little bench here to hang out and
we got the holes right down here a Big
Buddy Heater even some room for sleeping
bags boys get tired they can take naps
we could even camp out here if we want
maybe two feet yes is that electric
electric oh it's electric dude
big Hooks and big lures for big fish the
lake trout are the size of salmon and
bigger they're huge oh did you bring ice
in a cooler for your fish
I don't think we need that I think
they'll be ice just fine it was good all
right yeah we'll be good some white fish
white fish that I caught yep
it's like that that little thing right
here is an electronic light that turns
on when it hits water flashes Green in
there oh yeah yeah you got a little
green flash that's it oh look look at
these little rod holders here so we
stick that in there
we can leave that one now and go to
another hole and when it gets hit we
won't run over there and set the hook
foreign
hit the bottom and then kind of Bounce
It Up and Down off the bottom a few
times and let it sit
on
or fishing on the edge of a slope so
we're getting progressively deeper and
deeper the farther away from the shack
we go but we got it staggered so we can
fish at different depths and kind of see
where the fish are Tommy how you doing
you staying warm
good
there's something on there come on top
is your Rod you know what that is Tom
what that's a bourbon
there's a bourbon
look at that
there we go my very first bourbon
they're kind of like a eel like some
people call them eel pod freshwater Cod
they get much bigger than this I think
it's kind of about an average size what
you think yeah that's about average they
really look a lot like the Japanese
catfish
there we go oh nice
get him flattened out and Frozen up oh
Jake's Jake's got a fish
I think Jake got one in the ice shack
you guys got one
look at that it's a nice fish
what do you want a picture
just like that perfect here hold up look
at me
there we go
it was a pretty sweet setup we've got
rods and rod holders in a big circle all
around us at different depths and
they've got alarms on them and we could
just sit out here and keep an ear out
for the alarm and run and go get fish
boys can warm up in the ice shack and
and the best part is I didn't have to
rig everything up and set it all off
[Music]
look at that Ransom Hustle
oh yeah
there we go yep it's nice and smooth now
yeah
the beautiful bourbon
whoa
I don't think there's anything on it
you guys gotta ride the snow machine a
little bit
all right
[Music]
you can see the sun over there on the
horizon it's uh go to set in about two
hours it's almost 2 p.m so we've got to
get ready for night time it gets dark
really quick in the winter time here
I jerked that right out of his mouth
we'll set that back see if we get him
you guys doing okay in here
are you guys having fun though yeah it's
warm in here I'm gonna step outside and
eat my lunch
oh hello
at a time
oh yeah I heard that alarm go off I just
go
oh that is a nice one look at that nice
bourbon I think that's the biggest one
we've seen you know what
all right
that's nice
[Music]
and I did it inside
last time we were out here we caught all
lake trout I was like oh man I really
want to catch a bourbon Patrick's like I
got you this time that door shut every
time I try to pull out my uh my lunch
this verbit cup is it Cornish pasty it's
a British pastry I got kind of a
non-traditional one this one's got uh
apples raisins pork and little nutmeg
and cinnamon smeared some bacon fat in
there too because Bacon fat makes
everything better
Hey Jake
we gotta get you a fish buddy well the
sun's starting to set traditionally
that's a good time to catch lake trout
so who knows we might start hooking up
some Lakers come on Jacob come on
come on Jake
can you reel it
is
oh look at that
it's a bourbon
[Music]
good job Jake
do you like that yeah all right we keep
this one if he's uh in bad shape well
this one's swallowed it good too so
we're gonna keep him we got two bourbon
we're gonna have some nice Suburban to
eat
[Music]
you're gonna go back in the ice shack I
don't blame you it's getting cold out
here it's 3 30 in the afternoon the
sun's setting so I gotta bust out my
headlamps here we're gonna be night
fishing real quick temperatures also
dropping it doesn't feel like it's the
balmy 12 degrees than it was earlier
today
finally get your gloves on and you
realize you need to turn your camera off
really hard to operate a GoPro with
these mittens on
Justin
there we go another bourbon
yeah some bird po-boy
yeah
come on top
you got him oh
you got oh nope you don't have it yeah
go get warmed up dog he's doing really
well for all he having his dad's jacket
over
here
oh mermaid that's a big part of it big
daddy version
[Music]
good job Tom high five
well we are tearing up the bourbon we
are gonna have some good food but I've
lost Canada how many fish we caught but
we're gonna be here for a couple days so
we're not gonna push the boys hard we're
gonna go and get some warm dinner and
relax and just have a little fun and
we're gonna start this up again tomorrow
morning and hopefully tomorrow we'll get
into some big lake trout
foreign
there he goes there you go guys get your
feet warmed up let's go find some dinner
uh Ransom you like your hamburger
good today my little Jacob's turning
four years old he's a big boy so I asked
you this do you all right everyone out
into the frigid cold
yeah we might see the Northern Lights
tonight says there's a chance every time
it depresses you
all right guys you gotta go to the
bathroom you wait here Tom
there's the heater
come on
get in bed all right Tom
you Warp
right well it's bedtime for these guys
so I'm gonna turn this off and see you
guys in the morning
it's 7 30 in the morning and it's a
little bit cold in here there's frost on
the inside of our door
I'll have to go use the Outhouse oh I
gotta tell you number twosies are so
cold going to the bathroom almost killed
me it's cold I think maybe we should use
a lot of hand warmers today how about
what do you think of that
yeah
well guys it is significantly colder
outside
now yeah
see me
all right
[Applause]
you can feel it in your nose when it's
negative 20 it makes your boogers freeze
come on guys into the cabin let's get
you dressed let's see
joke
[Music]
we got about five minutes out in the
cold before my camera dies it needs to
get reheated
and uh my fingers got maybe 10.
got some white fish this is not tile
foreign
let me know if you get anything okay let
me go set up the other stuff
and negative 20 the holes ice over very
quickly so when they ice over the fish
can be tugging and nothing will happen
to the rod you won't even know it we
gotta keep the holes clear now it's
going to be a full-time job
thank you
one nice thing about the weather you
don't need a cooler
you guys having fun
awesome I'm happy to break the ice out
of the holes every 10 minutes
the 33 degree water from the lake is
steaming like a cup of hot chocolate
it's cold out here guys
there we go
that's beautiful all right let's get
back in the hole it's cold out here
boy there we go we got one hell by
ourselves these rats has got one
all right you got it Ransom
oh look at the head on that thing
[Music]
let's pull that puppy out look at that
nice bourbon look at that that was good
oh you may have noticed Patrick's not
with us today we decided to hire his
full-blown guide service for the first
day and then just rent the gear for the
second and it's working out really nice
you know we're catching fish on our own
and it's just uh just a fun kind of
different experience if you guys want to
do this yourself I'll put a link down in
the description below to chasing tails
Guide Service
Hey Jake how you doing are you keeping
warm
all the way out here you can see you oh
oh it's good to see you yeah I'm just
going around to all the holes and
getting rid of the ice you want to come
get rid of the ice with me so
do you need to use the potty
do you need to go pee or poo
H oh
all right we're gonna have to poop at
negative 20. can you do it
okay I think was that cold
yeah that was super cold all right let's
get you some snacks shall we it's a
little bit of time for a lunch break
we got uh little mabidofu Bento here
we're just walking around from Rod to
Rod clearing out the ice and checking on
things and it's kind of nice keeps you
warm
and if I keep my camera down my shirt
and under my armpit it stays warm enough
where I can film back into my armpit
what do you think bourbon or Laker I'm
gonna guess perfect oh oh Dan wow that's
the biggest lake turn of the trip so far
look at that nice lake trout Dan oh
that's nice Dad
now our hands are so cold yeah Dan
didn't even know that one was on there
he was just kicking the ice out and uh
once he did that he found the fish
that Sun's getting low must be 2 P.M
[Applause]
foreign
let's check out the boys and see how
they're doing
everyone's rocking out to fly to the
Valkyries
zombie are you doing well you're warm
yes Ransom you good I'm doing great Ben
you're doing good oh yeah oh yeah I got
my yogurt
you need to poop Jake yes
yeah
checks the rides out
are you having fun yeah
yes look at your eyelashes have frosted
them
it's time to start cleaning things up
getting packed up here
[Music]
come on Jake
it's negative 21 degrees outside and
poor Jacob just bit it face first in the
snow getting off the snow machine that
was so cold
very many times well guys let me unload
the snow machine and then we'll get it
ready and go to dinner okay
[Music]
your burger all right
come on in quickly quickly come on in
come on
it's negative 24 outside and the only
thing keeping us from hypothermia is uh
this little space heater right here it's
uh it's still real nippy in here so
we're gonna get in our sleeping bags
we're gonna cuddle up under some
blankets and you guys want to watch the
movies
oh good morning well we're all awake
oh yeah
oh
there's the generator well the generator
just died I think it's a side that we
should get packed up and go home is when
you do this
[Music]
oh we got a little bit of snow coming
down got a fair amount of it last night
look
yeah feels like it's above zero right
now it's actually quite nice
this we're gonna ratchet strap our fish
to the back of a car yeah some people
strap deer to the front of their trucks
we strap bourbon to the back of an SUV
yeah that's that's good that's good
burbot strapping right there good stuff
you go the wrong way Jacob well Patrick
we had a great time thank you so much
you're welcome yeah listen guys if
you're ever in Alaska and you're Lake
Louise and you want to go to do some
awesome ice fishing check out Patrick's
Guide Service chasing tails I'm gonna
put link down in the video description
below all right man I'll see you guys
next time we'll be back
what are we at three degrees
now
foreign
well it took a few hours but the bourbon
are thawed out and I think it's time to
Flame them up
yeah they're still a little stiff but I
think we can make it work
let's get on the verb it's really thin
and they have almost no scales they just
have these tiny little scales so you
could fry up the skin and eat it just
like you could salmon and it wouldn't be
a big deal at all
right
nice chunk of belly meat
[Music]
there's no y bones to worry about so
this isn't like a pike or a lot of other
fish
okay
just gonna go ahead and stick that in
the fridge and then tomorrow we're gonna
have a little bit of a dinner party
we're gonna have some friends over and
uh we're gonna cook up those bourbon
[Music]
foreign
throw some fish in there load it up with
as much as you want got the sweet chili
sauce on there I like to smear it on the
bread float up as many veggies as you do
or you don't want go for it remember if
you hate it just spit it all out off
camera
it's a nice clean white meat I mean it's
um it's not as firm and Flaky as halibut
but it's you know it's a pretty simple
straightforward white meat it's not as
muddy as catfish so that works out
pretty good I like that
what do you think did you like it was it
good thing is good all right well listen
do you guys enjoy the bourbon yeah yeah
yeah good well listen hopefully you guys
enjoyed watching this as much as we
enjoyed catching them Liz if you guys
want to see more videos from the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every Saturday morning thanks for
watching if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button and
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]